hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled
navigate the pandemic through laboratory
operational excellence
i'm susie valdez of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
and brought to you by abbott to learn
more visit them at
abbott.com so let's get started before
we begin i want to remind everyone that
this event is interactive and we
encourage you to participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
simply click on that support tab found
at the top right of the presentation
window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of your
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits i now present today's
speaker rubatrod a lab manager at
clemensu medical center
affiliated with john hopkins medicine
international for a complete
biography of our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen
reuben welcome you may now begin your
presentation
okay thank you bridget for this
introduction i'm really excited
to be here and to share my experience
and thank you for joining me in this
webinar
i had the opportunity to join
clemensville medical center 15 years ago
when it started
its operation i had deliberate i had
designed and commissioned it in beirut
and did the same as well with our sister
hospitals in
golf area my
my main focus was on laboratory
automation which we worked it really
inexpensively
and i had opportunity to launch the
first lab automation
system in beirut lebanon and
supported the same in our two sister
hospitals in the
in dubai and um
all right um today's talk is about
navigating the pandemic through
laboratory operational
excellence uh just uh
as a start to tell you that this
information is based on
my own ex laboratory experience and this
lnth series is not currently available
in all countries including
the united states
furthermore i would like to recognize
the effort of one holistic
multi-disciplinary team
that included the lab the engineering
and the i.t team under under the support
and
information of my director dr
baba a whole team from the senior
quality officers to coordinators
and the lab technologists they worked
holistically in order to ensure
continuous improvement initiatives
our our talk today will be
first of all introducing our medical
center and talk a bit
about our project and how we have worked
on
implementing it then we go thoroughly
into some solution benefits and how it
had an
impact on our operation and then we will
share with you the outcomes of the study
that we have collected some data and
analyzed to
uh to support these operational
excellence initiatives
and we will share with you at the end
what we have done
during the government pandemic and how
this laboratory automation has helped us
to
go through and still going on till today
as an introduction clemonsville medical
center is a medical center located
in center of beirut lebanon
158 bed hospital with 11 o.r and 40
clinics
our mission and vision is to provide the
state-of-the-art technology
to our patients in the in lebanon and
in the region and we have created
certain
centers of excellence in certain areas
including
radiotherapy and robotic surgery we are
affliated with
john hopkins medicine international and
we are gci accredited
and our latest award was the 2019
mtqa for the best hospital for medical
tourism
and yet we are striving for more in the
future
as far as our lab overview as you can
see
our volume is around 400 500 000 uh
tests per year it we have transitioned
from the legacy
uh systems of pacman to all eleninity
aids
our main challenges uh in the lab in the
corlap project
mainly was uh budget constraints uh
limited space which we'll talk
deeply later on and as well as increased
demand
due to hospital expansion especially
during uh
especially for medical tourism as well
as during covert 19
pandemic
if we just check the lab
layout before as you can see it was a
very traditional laboratory starting
with having several benches
uh separating each section from it
and not really connected
uh if you can see if we go from the
right to the left we had
the blood gas and uh receiving
area then we go through the hematology
and coagulation section
the second bench was mainly for
immunology
reaching at the end to the chemistry
what we have discussed with the abbott
team is to have
more like a streamlined process and to
decrease
the non added value of steps for staff
and we ended up of having
a core lab almost in the middle where
all these systems
and components have been integrated
bringing much more space
to the lab and leaving all the benches
at the out
uh at the sides for other uh specialized
tests such as autoimmune allergy testing
as well as for manual testing
and this has give us much more space if
you want to have
future uh expansion uh it's worth noting
that the size
the the space of the lab is around 120
meters square now why we have chosen
abbot
it is aligns with our strategic goals in
terms of introducing
uh new new services that are
evidence-based and thus controlling cost
but most importantly
it helps us in our regional expansion as
you know cmc
is expanding in the gulf area we already
have two
uh sister hospitals one in dubai and one
in riyadh and we wanted
one system that is able uh to be
installed in all our hospitals whereby
our staff
can work in the other institution
about decreasing the time for training
and uh
and staff development uh
this journey has started in february
2016
and uh it took us around two years to
make to the uh
to finalize the project it was initiated
in december 2000 yet it was in december
2019
and we went live almost by may 2017
covering
all uh laboratory automation components
uh
it is worth noting that the study that
we're going to discuss uh
later well is between may 2019 and
august 2019
uh phase um it is very important to say
that the apple team really helped us
uh transition from the legacy to uh
to alinity in a very smooth way and and
very efficient way we were able to
from the installation in december to go
live
uh maximum by may finalizing
all engineering i.t as well as quality
studies we are also scmc committed for
continuous improvement and finding
new opportunities to improve
efficiencies and that is why currently
you are in phase two
of the study after uh following that the
lnth
went live and we are starting to plan
and design for the
faith phase three in 2021 where would
which will include the installation and
the implementation of miq risk
stratification
software
now now we have uh we have evaluated uh
the lab automation project
uh for by creating an objective
uh matrix uh that is referred into four
components that are
very crucial and important mainly lab
engineering financial and information
each each one has
a certain emphasis uh thus covering
uh all these aspects into 15 indicators
and out of these 15 indicators
abbott has covered almost 14 as compared
to uh to the other brands in the market
now if we go
next if we go to our uh solution benefit
the solution benefits mainly we're going
to highlight uh the most important
aspects that has an impact on our daily
operation
on our quality of results when we want
to compare
the legacy instruments versus allenity
and what had had an impact on our
patients results first of
all we have to emphasize on the
alienated uniformity in terms of
chemistry immunoassays and hematology
the the user interface uh is
was very helpful and we have seen its
impact
uh in our training of staff
our staff
very hard we say um
very very comfortable to move from one
uh analyzer to another and that's what
made us to change
our recruitment uh strategy uh
previously
uh with our legacy we always recruited
uh staff with having more experience
because
they were most of the time releasing
results based on
their critical thinking as well as their
experience
now with the apple club automation
components
we are more confident to to
recruit a fresh graduate and
we are really confident that they will
safely release
patient uh results and we were going to
have
and their training uh period has been
decreased like any
technologist having more than three
years of experience
um these and
and since we implemented uh this project
in may 2019 till today
uh we have around 70 percent of our core
lab
staff performed the cross training in
all section and this will provide
us some mobility and flexibility to
ensure
uh rostering and coverage of the
operation
the second important benefit
is the essay performance we have also
observed that we have an increase in
assay
linearity affecting the decrease in
the dilutions and we run mainly as you
can see in
hepatic enzymes reaching up to 8 000
like in gamma gt
and it has improved our turnaround time
the calibration frequency also has
decreased by 57
percent in most essays especially like
in the un and that has
that we used to do daily calibration now
we're doing it almost
on weekly basis as well as like
protein we're doing it currently on a
monthly basis rather than doing it on
daily basis
and the total uh manual staff time saved
by then was
around 146 hours the third
uh point that we'd like to highlight is
the ict module which is
which is by itself a revolutionary
technology
as you all know electrolytes is a very
tedious it's very important also analyte
we have faith
with our previous analyzers problems
with maintenance preventive maintenance
water quality
uh issues with the electrodes as well as
the probes that we had to continuously
change them
and now with the ict module we are able
to have
stable and accurate results
the fourth issue is the overall
automation
benefit the automation benefit in terms
of attract
that had an added value uh with uh
for abbott is the open connectivity
the track when we have decided in 2016
we had a list of
around 26 uh uh non-abbot analyzers that
are that can be connected uh to the
track including floor cytometry
molecular as well as urine analysis
that made us to look for opportunities
to expand our menu
thus without the need of an additional
technologist or expertise
the scalability of instruments is very
interesting and very important
uh when you need to add up
more instruments having a limited space
and this will give us business
opportunities to expand our workflow
i would like to highlight on the
introduction of the quantitative hil
index
once we have introduced it it has saved
a lot of time and
helped us also to identify
certain increase and results due to
a high hemolysis or high accuracy rate
and sometimes at the micro level
that usually were not detected by our
technologist manually
this implementation has it reduced the
manual step by almost 77 percent
and thus also eliminated manual errors
well one workflow we have introduced two
major components that were not
previously
available the first is the helicopter
and the second one is the online storage
uh the allocator we have encountered
in order to perform the coding for
samples that require
outsourced testing and it will do direct
labeling that's decreasing or
pre-analytical
uh errors and and also in terms of
saving the volume especially for
pediatrics and elderly and patients with
physical
veins we have studied this aspect by
looking at the number of
tube chemistry tubes consumed in 2018
versus 2019 and there was almost a drop
of 18
our previous practice was that we needed
to collect
three chemistry tubes per patient one
for chemistry one for endocrinology
and one for the outsourced testing and
now it has been reduced to one
the second important component
that has saved a lot of time for us is
the storage module this the online
storage module has a capacity of around
9000 tubes
uh it allowed us to expand uh the sample
stability from two hours to seven days
for mainly for the chemistry analyzers
and especially for the hepatic enzymes
it also allowed us is to retrieve any
sample when we have add-ons
and from the
the requested by the patient and this
has increased also the physician and the
patient
satisfaction
the element middle where the ms
middleware had various
uh improvement at at all levels from
tests to sample management reaching
quality
the historical reports helped us to
understand
the the current data that we have and
help us also use
those data in order to look for more
ways of improvement and we will share
them with you
shortly one of the major issues that we
never had it before and currently we are
able to
have them is the ability to er and the
trees
uh the increased visibility and
traceability for essays and analyzers
when it comes to panic values
from a patient care point of view as
well as when we have
overview when we look wanted to look at
uh
recalls in any order to evaluate any
reagent
and its impact on the patient results
that were reported back then
in the ams middleweight i would like to
highlight more on the autoverification
rule
one of the analysis
data analysis that we're using is the
auto verification
rate which is the percent
of results that have been automatically
released
from the software rather
manually from the technologies having
passed
the auto verification rules as well as
the delta check
and when we looked at the data between
april and august 2020
we found that it is around 60.5 percent
which is acceptable
having working in a hospital setup
it is very interesting to highlight that
these
the ams allows us to have rules that are
really flexible
we are on daily basis working with our
quality
uh department and the it in order to
add up rules based on incidents based on
uh near misses that we might face on
daily basis and the system is very
flexible
by which it will allow us to modify and
implement this rules
for the better and the safety and
outcome one of an example which i can
highlight is the hba1c rule
by which if we had a mislabeling of
the cbc tube into a chemistry label that
might happen by a nurse or by a lab tech
and
and because of the load they couldn't
either identify that
this tube does not belong to the proper
container
uh we had put a rule to make hold of any
value of hba1c more than 10 percent
to eliminate this pre-analytical error
or to look for
possible analytics
another issue that we are working we
worked on and it saved us a lot of
tests and time is the test hold whenever
we have
any failure in quality control rule
whether random or systemic
uh the ams will push the machine
push the machine to hold the test and to
stop patient testing
until we solve the description control
discrepancy
the impact of the auto verification rule
is have seen in our modified result rate
by definition the modified modified
result rate
is any reason that that was reported to
the physician and was modified based on
pre-analytical post
analytical or post analytical error we
had an increase
in the rate in 2018 when we have when we
were manually
entering with the results and because of
the high load of the
of the volume that we had back then with
the limited number
of technologies that we have we ended up
having
many results that are ended empty
sometimes we were
we were misreporting those cases
because of the manual practices and when
we introduced
ams software this rate has decreased by
less than 0.02
which is in the core lab thus
providing a better outcome
when we look when we look at the
outcomes we have
we have designed the study to look at
various aspects
uh of the importance of this automation
to our lab
we started first of all with the space
utilization as i
as you recall our uh lab space is around
120
meters square and with the new design
and introduction of the alienity in
terms of space and throughput
our theoretical troop would have
increased by 33 percent and
our tests per square meter have
increased
200 percent
uh maintenance time the maintenance time
has decreased in total by 18 percent if
you want to compare the legacy versus
lnt however there was an 87
reduction in the manual maintenance time
so all those manual steps
have been eliminated and become
automated that is why the
impact on time was only by 18 percent
because of this major finding we have
shifted
those weekly maintenance activities uh
to
during weekends uh shifts where we have
less traffic
during the lab and also we have
pushed our staff that were working
during
uh during the weekends to to do
other uh duties in other sections such
as bacteriology and parasitology
so for more efficient use of resources
we looked at also at the total value of
ownership in terms of quality control
consumption
we currently use the bioware at the
third quarter
to control and we have seen a
50 percent reduction in the consumption
versus 2018 and this is had a huge
impact on
our resources this is mainly to the
low uh dead volume as well as the low
aspiration volume of
lility
uh another issue that was eliminated is
the sample preparation we used to do
pre-treatment for the sample in hba1c as
well as pre-treatment
of the reagent 40 ibc as you can see the
steps
and those steps has been eliminated with
a ready-to-use reagent
in lnt thus saving around 742 hours
annually in tech time
for the pre-analytical steps which is
the
steps that were handled from the time of
sample receipt to the
till the time the sample uh the test was
resulted and the sample was loaded it is
around
13 steps and this 13 step has been
decreased to only three steps in terms
of reception loading of tube and final
and load
thus providing a 77 percent improvement
all right uh so all these improvements
and all these outcomes so far has
allowed us to look
at the scheduling of the staff
previously
we had a nine hour shifts covering
around
10 technologies per day shifts for
example
these uh these the day shift has
been almost reduced by uh 33 percent
by changing our shifts into 12 hour
shifts
uh for part we had also other staff were
allocated to other
activities such as phlebotomy and
quality
management activities and that led
also to a 70 percent decrease in the
overtime
the last important uh outcome that we
looked at
is the turnaround time which is almost
uh
a major uh headache for all laboratories
we studied uh determinant time in 2018
versus 2019
and we saw there's a total of 53 percent
decrease
in turnaround time of 124 tests that are
run on chemistry strategy and not
chronology the major improvement in the
average is
in the chemistry by 94 percent the
improvement in endocrinology and geology
is almost 30
for the reason that we have only one lnt
uh
analyzer till now until we and
the carboxyl capacity allowed us to uh
prioritize which tests are more urgent
other than that that's why the impact is
only 30 percent
and we're looking forward to have it to
have it more when we introduce the
second
allenity analyzers
and the testimonial of our er director
is uh is a very important
their satisfaction is quite important
for us for mainly
our status
when it comes to the pandemic so
the first thing we look at when it comes
to automation we think of volume
we think of efficiencies we think of
how can we increase our workload and to
have
an excellent business model but when the
government 19 pandemic started in march
2020 uh
lab automation was not seen as being
a burden but but rather a relief
and a business saver for uh
for instance because it helped us to
overcome
so in lebanon the situation uh
started in march and we had like around
uh
three lockdown one complete and two
partial and currently
in november we are having the third
lockdown
uh our hospital decided
not to admit any covert 19 patients we
are only
uh covering screen of patients training
a patient and handling
certain patients in er before being
transferred
this provided more confidence to our
community
to come and to seek care for
non-covered diseases
and and until now the workload has not
really
uh decreased we have always increased uh
demand
in order for the lab to cope
with this new uh with this new situation
we had we faced three major challenges
how we have to ensure our staff safety
how we have to ensure our business
continuity
and how we have to have include a supply
edge an uninterrupted supply chain in
terms of staff safety
uh we have
decreased our day shifts from six people
per day
into three teams of two
peoples each in order to have different
teams covering the laboratory
uh 12 hours daily and enabling
us in case one of the teams got exposed
then
the operation would still uh be run
efficiently in terms of business
community continuity we have eliminated
certain um administrative staff of uh
tasks for the technologists and we
only focus on preventive maintenance on
quality control
uh in order to ensure quality of results
and thus
without affecting any turn around time
and we have
since we have partnered with a strong
distributor
uh he we work together to collaborate to
ensure
that we have a proper inventory
having delays in our the courier
services with the lockdown of the
airport
and increased and the delay in the
production
in certain products on the other hand
these delays have been compensated by
the reagent packaging because
um alinity's reagent package is around
almost for certain analytes are 1000
other is around 4 000
tests so uh as well as for endocrinology
it's around 200 tests this would allow
us uh
to use efficiency to to consume those
uh tests uh with an extended time until
we get
our new shipment in our previous
legacy we had only around 100 test
package which
we might fall into a problem facing such
a pandemic
so our take-home message is more
mainly uh focused on that the life
evaluation criteria has proven to be a
strong objective criteria that helped us
to
highlight and benefits
uh that are very important to us and to
exploit and decision upon
and yet those benefits have been
translated into positive outcome
that were highlighted in our study more
more also that scmt
has realized that improvement in both
operational excellence and
integrated clinical care is very
important
once we have implemented the apple total
solution in beirut
and that's why when we chose a strong
partner we have
we have decided to standardize our
system in our affiliate
hospitals in the gulf region finally
the gains that you are currently had
when we
when we implemented
those operational efficiencies in cmc
during the pandemic has increased
the high level of patient care that we
have aimed to and we are
bound to provide in lebanon
thank you so much for listening and i'm
ready to hear all your questions
thank you ruben for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of our webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
so it looks like rebel we already have
some great questions coming in from our
audience member
what are your plans around risk
stratification
at clemensu medical center
uh thank you for this interesting
question
uh as you all know cardiovascular
diseases
is increasing and it is a prominence in
lebanon and in the middle east so um
our cardiology department is really
active and we looked around to see how
can we help
our patients as physician to identify uh
the best source for risk for coronary
diseases
uh risk assessment and when we partnered
with abbott we have worked with them on
a project
of attend it's a new software called miq
bridge classification
it is a software that allows
us to identify
the risk of having any myocardial
infarction
incident we will be working on
the implementation of the software in
2021
and we're going to run around a one-year
study to evaluate it for our population
and we're so excited about it it's
because it's gonna
provide us more insight about
the potential risks and mainly its
impact on
age and gender because we now
we rarely are able to identify uh
events in young people which are less
than 40 years of age and it is quite
common
in our uh region thank you
our next question from our audience
members are
how did the laboratory manage the
transition to ensure there were no
disruption to service
levels and patient care
well this is a very important and a
strong question
because it was a great challenge for us
we have
really planned planned it with the
abbott team as well as with our
engineering and i.t
department who who all of them played a
major role
to ensure that our 24 hour 7 operation
is uninterrupted and our turnaround time
and patient
care also is not affected so
what we have done we've planned um as
you all remember from the slide
uh our space is around 120 meters square
so we divided the area into a four into
four
sections and what we do that each time
we we do uh we moved all uh
the um the analyzers in this section on
a mobile unit
and we moved as well and all the
infrastructure
the water systems the network and
everything
it's what was mobile uh during that time
and and and the technologies would be
running the samples and at the same time
in parallel
the engineers and the it would prepare
the infrastructure as designed
at the same time so our concerns
was during that period when we had uh
two areas one uh running and the other
one
being under construction is to ensure
the employee's safety
so uh we had the opportunity
to mobilize those analyzers without
being affected in terms of quality and
and their performance
in a way ensuring that
the employees are being safe and not
being disrupted
this whole plan took around 30 days
30 non-stop days including weekends and
with this and during that time the
quality team in our lab was monitoring
the incidents at the turn around time
and i'm really happy to say that during
this 30 days
we only had three er samples
delayed in reporting the turnaround time
to rather than 60 minutes to 72 minutes
maximum
but other than that we had a remarkable
operation thank you
and thank you so much ruba and i want to
thank our audience members for these
great questions coming in
our next question in addition to
reduction in staff time
due to automation have you seen a
reduction in
errors
so um well definitely
we have set several kpis in order to
identify and
monitor if the incidence as well as
the reduction of those error mainly we
checked the modified
uh result rate in order to identify to
see a reduction
major in clavicle errors we also
have noticed that there was a decrease
in the frequency of
the random quality control failures
especially in endocrinology and hepatic
enzymes
and this has to do with two major issues
one of them is the increased reagent
stability
as compared to the legacy analyzers as
well as
the automated steps in the preventive
maintenance procedures and these
automated steps
had a major impact because previously we
used to do them manually
and we had a repetitive increase in
aspiration errors
when those prevented maintenance in
terms of
cleaning and pushing the probes has been
done automated
though the aspiration errors have
decreased tremendously and thus
affecting the quality control
performance
thank you so much ruben we have time for
one more question
with covet cases beginning to increase
across the globe
is there anything your laboratory is
doing to prepare for the second
wave differently than what's already
been done
the government 19 at pandemic has pushed
us
always on alert and always trying to be
prepared and try to force you
things it's not always working but you
try as much as possible so after we
passed the first wave
currently we are in the second wave yet
we tried
earlier in in august and september
to prepare for it and to learn from the
first wave as much as possible
so what we did we did three major things
first of all we
screened our employees to check for past
and current exposure to covet 19
and accordingly uh based on those
results we have
modified our staff schedule from three
teams to two teams
each team of three members rather than
two
because we have seen that there is an
increased demand in our
hospital especially in the er and we
need to be able to
uh to handle those increase and workload
efficiency
by ensuring as well our staff safety
uh second of all uh
we have centralized all our routine
testing and samples on the track
with the with the go live of the mnet h
on
in september uh 2020 which allowed
us also to be to increase our efficiency
uh third thing our ministry of health
lebanese minister of health has set a
new guidelines requesting
us to handle or cope with 19
patients and under the hood and in a
closed
system and to centrifuge them in a
separate centrifuge
uh the ministry has exempted us from
this task because
we already have a closed system that is
able to handle
all the specimen from the loading from
centrifugation till the uploading
uh closely thus ensuring the safety of
our employees so we do consider
all our samples received in the lab as
infectious so we
we will not be differentiated over 19
patients compared to
not go with 19 patients
thank you so much ruba and i want to
thank you for your presentation today
did you have any final comments for our
audience before we go
okay um yes bridge i would like to
highlight one more thing one important
thing that what i have learned from this
project
and still learning that it is um
operational excellence cannot be done
unless it is enough
with the team and we need to look at it
from a multidisciplinary approach it's
not always about
quality it should be quality it should
be safety and it should be
continuous thrive to to reach certain
satisfaction
and uh i have i have
uh i'm pushing always my team to look
for
ways and uh and initiatives
or what we can do better and how we can
integrate
at the lab the lab to be uh with other
uh healthcare uh institution as well as
with other
healthcare partners because uh the
laboratory
being the core lab of a hospital it is
also should be
a progressive and
provide insights to physicians and
patients so uh
this is a road we started and it would
be
my administration has said and
i'm looking forward in order to achieve
it in the future
thank you all for listening and thank
you all for uh for this wonderful
question
and thank you again ruba for your time
today and for your important research
and i want to thank lab roots and our
sponsor abbott for underwriting today's
educational webcast
and before we go i want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
labrets will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time stay safe
and stay healthy take care everyone bye